AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME --
2015 PREDICTIONS.
2014 WAS A WHIRLWIND OF A
YEAR.
WE STARTED OUR SHOW, BASICALLY,
THERE WERE QUARRENTINES,
THERE WERE NAKED PICTURES OF
CELEBRITIES, SETH ROGEN AND
JAMES FRANCO ALMOST INCITED
THE NEXT NUCLEAR WINTER.
HOW COULD 2015 POSSIBLY STOP
THAT?
YOU TELL ME, COMEDIANS! I WANT
YOU TO COME UP WITH AS MANY
PREDICTIONS FOR THIS YEAR AS YOU
CAN.
LET'S PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
NIKKI.
>> BRUCE JENNER WILL
COMPLETE HIS TRANSITION INTO
A GLAMOROUS SCARE CROW.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
JON DALY.
>> JOHNNY DEPP WILL CONSUMMATE
HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
MARILYN MANSON.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
RON FUNCHES.
>> E BOLLA 2: JUDGEMENT DAY.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
RON FUNCHES.
>> MEDICINAL HEROIN.
>> CHRIS: I GET THESE -- I GOT
THESE STIFF JOINTS.
NIKKI GLASER.
>> MISSOURI LEGALALIZES
GAY MARRIAGE, BUT JUST TO
PISS OFF THE PARENTS.
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
JON DALY.
>> THE UBER MURDERS OF 2015.
>> CHRIS: RON FUNCHES.
>> UNDATABLE IS THE NUMBER ONE
NEW COMEDY IN THE WORLD.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: I SAID PREDICTION, IN
THE FANTASIES.
POINTS. NIKKI GLASER.
>> A RICH OLD WHITE MAN
MAKES MAY BIRTH CONTROL MORE
EXPENSIVE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> TOO REAL?
YEAH.
TOO REAL.
>> CHRIS: JON DALY.
>> BOY HOOD 2: BOY HOODER.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS. -- BOY
HOODER.